what's it like to work for Vladimir
Putin we speak to one Russian Diplomat
now in exile for speaking out against
the war in Ukraine
[Music]
good evening the war in Ukraine is
entering a new era this week attacks on
the capital Kiev have continued and
President Putin has ordered martial law
in the areas of Ukraine now annexed by
Russia but does Putin have the support
of his people Boris bondarev spent a
decade working at the Russian foreign
Ministry working as a diplomat in
Switzerland he put his life at risk and
spoke out against The Invasion and has
spent the last eight months in Exile Mr
bondarev knows the inner workings of the
Kremlin and what Putin could be planning
next
borrespondarev thank you so much for
talking to us on Sky News Today on the
Beth Rigby interview show I've got so
much that I want to talk to you about
and I want to get into your time in
Russia and working under President Putin
but fast you quit as a senior Diplomat
in May 2020 after 20 years working as a
career diplomat but three months after
the invasion of Ukraine it was both I
would say a brave but potentially
dangerous thing for you to do but you
did it why yes I did greet from civil
service in May 2022
um though my decision was taken on
February 24 2022 in the day when Russia
illegally and unlawfully and
unjustifiably attacked Ukraine so for me
it was like
uh like a personal thresholds Crossing
which I realized that I could not any
longer work for this government for this
regime for this country for my country
because my country now under the
leadership of President Putin and his
accomplices now is making war crimes and
terrible mistakes and crimes against our
future Generations
because now we see that Russia is going
to be more and more isolated is going
more and more lost and that is a
terrible crime huge Pride not only
against Ukraine but against Russians
themselves Russian diplomats have been
going around the world saying these are
just training exercises on the border
there is no intention to invade in the
run-up to February the 24th did you
think President Putin is going to do
this I personally did not believe that
President Putin was seriously going to
start the War I told myself that
it's most probably it all was like a
part of a huge diplomatic and political
game like we concentrated our troops
along the Ukrainian borders in order to
press on Ukraine and on NATO to you know
to make some concessions and so on so
it's it's a it's a huge and sometimes
cruel but it's still for politics it's
not the war and so I to the last day I
convinced myself that that may not be so
so bad as it as it turned out to be so
yes so the start of war was you know a
little bit unexpected to me so miss
Ponder when you saw that those tanks
were going across the border where were
you at that moment and how did you feel
well I just woke up in my general
apartment I
turn to my smartphone just to check the
news and I saw this footages on of gear
from height of bond by Russian aircraft
and all these traffic jams of people
trying to flee here it was terrible you
know last time Keith was born by the
Nazi luftwaffe in 1941.
and it was unimaginable for me as a
Russian who was born in Soviet Union you
know to imagine that Russia May attack
Ukraine our closest neighbor
it's a you know it's it's like England
attacks Scotland you know nowadays it's
I don't think you can imagine that but
then then that's I I understood that it
is the beginning of the end of which on
government of which in the regime I want
to come on to the beginning of the end
for Putin and all of that um later in
the interview but
you then
defected effectively
were you afraid well yes I was a little
bit afraid because
um you know
I I had I had some familiar like Affairs
to to be settled before I could quit
those time was very tense for me and
when I every every day I came to my
office and I took to talk to people
there whom I considered to be reasonable
and professional and after it was
started they all turned out to be like
were mongering and very content with
what is what was going on and it was
very you know very hard to endure those
conversations but just to be clear you
do you think you will ever be able to
now go back to Russia and certainly not
for the foreseeable future you would not
be safe would you I don't think it would
be okay for me to go back to Russia
while the current uh government is in
place if there are some changes in
Russia of course and Mr Putin is gone
we all hope it will not take long
so then yes I think I will go back of
course because it's my my home my home
country you know I and if I can be
useful I can be useful there there have
been a number of deaths linked to the
Kremlin famously Alexander lipvinyenko
uh it's thought at least eight Russian
businessmen have died in apparent
suicides or accidents in just six months
I put it to you you're a very brave man
you know I I don't think much about this
and I
I do not overestimate my importance you
know I'm just a middle middle level
Diplomat maybe I'm only one who resigned
publicly but anyway it's not that I am
you know I'm not a very important figure
in Russian government so to speak in
most beautiful sense it must be very but
very few people uh speak out against the
regime don't then there's a reason for
that I believe that most people are
either blindly believing that President
Putin his government are right and are
doing the right thing
or they just don't want to be bothered
you know with any thoughts about what is
going on they just doing their job
in the narrow sense of this world so
it's many many people they do they do
the job they don't want to be you know
distracted from their day-to-day routine
because to be distracted to to analyze
the reality would take you a lot of you
know your internal internal strengths
and capacity and it may be very tiresome
for you and people don't want to get
tired because daily daily life in Russia
gets worse and worse every day and you
have to have your own strength you know
so I can understand those people and
also uh for many years for decades
Russian Civil Service
has been recruited
people people for civil service have
been recruited on the criteria of
personal loyalty and mostly not on the
Criterion of professionalism and
competence basically people that would
challenge or question get removed or
leave the structures in Russia in sense
that you end up with a president where
no one actually speaks truth to power at
all well yeah yeah I think if the the
there were people in Russian government
I mean close with President Putin who
could
voice the
concerns regarding some decisions we may
we may not see this very tragic
situation but evidently there are not
such people there and last time I
remember it was in 2018 when there was a
sleepian crisis
yes and there was an opposition within
the American Faith to the decision of
no-fly zone over Libya and this
opposition was suppressed by government
by then president and after that I I
haven't seen any other like more or less
formal opposition within the Ministry of
Foreign Affairs to any government a
decision or a proposal let's get on to
policy in President Putin now up until
this year you worked for the Russian
foreign Ministry and you served as an
advisor on nuclear non-proliferation can
you just explain what your job was to
our viewers I worked in Geneva
since 2019 in our design team so we
mostly were in charge of conference on
this Armament and all other discernment
related matters which are discussed in
Geneva such as
nuclear non-proliferation treaties such
as biological weapons prevention and
some other multilateral instruments
and also we
dealt with the Strategic stability on
the issue of nuclear deterrence it seems
that Putin is more interested now in the
threat of using nuclear weapons and
deploying them than he is in
non-proliferation that is so clear there
have been reports that he wants to
detonate potentially a nuclear warhead
over the Black Sea
what do you think's going on I believe
that there can be some plans to somehow
employ the nuclear weapons during this
the war in Ukraine I cannot say of
course what those plans can be and can
look like but I think every General
stuff every means of Defense has some
such contingency contingency plans
um and of course when President Putin
spreads of threatens to use nuclear
awareness and he does it repeatedly it
doesn't help you know to strengthen in
non-proliferation regime
worldwide because many countries would
see now that if you have nuclear weapons
you can use them for like the blackmail
your neighbors or other countries to get
some benefits from them so it is very
interesting fact that nuclear weapons
now thanks to President Putin now they
becoming not the instrument for
deterrence as they have been up till now
but they become the instrument of
of compelling other countries to do
whatever you want from them
out of the threat of being nuked so it's
totally new level of history of nuclear
weapons now
and it is very dangerous of course very
dangerous development the question is
when he threatens to use them does he
mean it could he use them
well technically I think yes
you can order to use them and I don't
think that there will be many generals
or other Military Officers who would say
that no we would not execute these
orders because it is like suicide or it
is a Warcraft I'm I'm afraid there will
be people who will say okay no problem
with that and they press the button
or whatever it is
but whether Putin will use it you know
it is mostly I think it depends not on
him
because it depends on how the West which
is the main addressee of this nuclear
blackmail How the West is reacting to
that
and for now I see that this reaction is
very is a bit appeasing
you know this Western leaders repeatedly
say that they don't want any escalation
so they restrict themselves they
restrict the help and assistance to
Ukraine they don't want to supply
Ukraine with more powerful more
long-range weapons for instance for
instance and so on so they demonstrate
that every possible moment they
demonstrate to Putin that they are ready
to play by his rules
so he has initiated in this so you know
this new game is first of all is
psychology psychology game it's like any
black male so if you confront it with
blackmail you have two options either
you
you surrender to this blackmailer and
you do whatever he wants from you or you
confront him to put him it all looks
like westerners are very weak and they
are not ready to fight
really to fight for themselves for peace
and so on it it emboldens him it
encourages him to press further and he
will be pressing further and further
until we are all at the moment when he
has no other option but to actually use
nuclear weapons so only thing that could
prevent from this scenario is to say
once and for all that no nuclear threats
is acceptable
the West must show its result
like UK show its results in 19 you know
39 and 1940 when there was a battle for
Britain with the with the nuts yes then
UK didn't surrender UK didn't abuse the
aggressor and the gay prevailed dementia
and the situation now is very similar to
what we we saw before the second world
war you know in the very beginning of
the second world do you think we're on
the cusp of the third world war yeah
yeah well Putin actually I think he's
assured that he is already waging the
third world war the world for
um to him it is the world for reshaping
the war the political map of the world
because he believed that he
he has too little
too little influence too little power on
the map that he is entitled to
and but also we must understand very
clearly that Putin and Russia are two
different things
when Putin says that something is
threatening Russia's interests so
Russia's security
he means only himself
because Russia is totally okay with NATO
Russian people especially younger
Generations they don't see NATO as some
kind of existential enemy or just Enemy
No they are totally okay with that
because well NATO is a defensive
Alliance
but Putin and his generation
who are still you know who are still
under this Soviets in Cold War era uh
propaganda
they see they think that they are
Russian
so for them it is
it is a spread to putting into his
regime this point of just to be clear
why what you're saying is that the
Allies the West's attempt to containment
of Putin fundamentally misunderstands
how he thinks and operates and that if
they don't become more robust and more
aggressive in supporting Ukraine to
defeat him militarily then they could
help trigger a nuclear war that's your
assessment my assessment is that if the
worst doesn't show enough strength and
resolve to fight back and to by fight
back I mean not necessarily because
militarily fighting but you know in
general terms then it will lead to
further stress from Putin the strategy
of led by President Biden is to try and
avoid escalation to try and avoid
further uh provoking President Putin
what you're saying is that is a
fundamental mistake I believe yes it is
because I mean when you say that you
don't want to provoke a bully it does
gives gives him a wrong signal
he gets it that you're afraid of him and
he must continue and escalate further
you must send the clear signal that if
put Advanced escalation he'll get it you
know and then he will he will get no
incentive to continue because he will
see that his threats are not working you
know he must understand that Putin made
all that he may change the course of War
he may reverse
his defeats into another uh wide scale
Onslaught on Ukraine
and I'm not sure that NATO's help will
be sufficient for ukrainians to defend
how important is it that President Biden
tries to tie in other nuclear Powers
tries to tie in China to try and deal
with Putin of course it's necessary to
unite as many countries as we can
against this aggression and China is a
key player in this because if anyone can
influence
Putin that may be presidency the problem
is that China I think is not very much
interested in the in the defeat of Putin
especially by ukrainians and by by
westerners because now Putin is
distracting a lot of attention from the
United States first of all the attention
that they
could refocus on China instead so China
I think will be very difficult to get
China apart on this anti-butin Coalition
or something
but it is necessary of course and then
oh China and India and all other main
main key major developing countries it
is very important
believe what
for much of your career on the
non-proliferation of nuclear weapons we
are where we are
when I listen to it it frightens me a
bit do you do you feel frightened
well of course nobody wants nuclear war
because you know if we started
some local military theater it will it
can easily grow into the full-scale
world nuclear war and then we will be
like
you know we will be leaving surviving in
radioactive Province but I think we
should should have this in mind and try
to make our our best to avoid this
scenario
but to avoid the scenario we cannot
avoid it through appeasement and through
surrendering ourselves you know because
it will not
cancel this threat it will just postpone
this war because you cannot surrender
indefinitely our planet is you know is
not that big
so
it is the if your opponent threatens you
with nuclear war well you must answer to
this and you said it's the beginning of
the end you don't know how long that is
we can talk a little bit in a minute
about how the end could look like but
he's losing this war isn't he when he
announced that draft of uh Russian men
drafted in uh to to to to to replete his
depleted forces it's estimated 700 000
Russians fled he's losing Well for now
yes it seems so but again if if the
Western World will continue to limit
himself itself in regard of the aid to
Ukraine then the war may still change
and they you know now the Russians are
bombing the civilian infrastructure
independent infrastructure of Ukraine
it's it now as president said it's 30
percent of energy infrastructure is out
order it's a very huge number so and
with this new Iranian uavs you know very
cheap and in great numbers there are
hopes in Russia that they can reverse
this the course of War
so it is you know the world war is not
predictable never goes according to plan
on both sides talking about reversing
the course of the war talking about the
Iranian uh drones uh the NATO has said
that it is going to send in more
supplies to try and better help the
ukrainians defend their critical
infrastructure it seems that the tactic
of Putin has now moved to raise in a
cray Ukraine and trying to just destroy
all of the infrastructure of the country
um is it enough what NATO is doing it
seems to me that you don't think it is
and so what I'd like you to ask you is
what do you think NATO needs to do now
to provide the defensive systems to
Ukraine it is very important of course
there's no doubt but it is not enough
evidently because if you only own your
defense then you are doomed to be on
defensive forever and the enemy will
help initiated and it will it will it
will be able to attack you from any any
any point any side and for ukrainians it
is crucial to have this initiative in
the war and for that they need offensive
weapons they need tanks they need more
long-range missile systems and so on
they need aircraft so I think NATO must
double down the the efforts and they
help what you're saying is that you
think that NATO Allied Forces should
have a limited deployment of troops to
help in the Ukraine war
maybe be that be fighter pilots but
there should be some limited deployment
well it's uh just like food for thought
it's up to military experts on it or
whether they are okay with that or not
but it's first of all about political
will of Native Native leaders whether
they want to get involved in this or not
the problem is is you know their what
their concern is if they for example in
no-fly zone zolenski's been asking for
it again and again again you presumably
think that they should Implement a
no-fly zone over Ukraine of course they
don't want to do that because they don't
want a direct confrontation with Russia
and it will it may provoke within again
to resort to nuclear weapons but as I'm
I'm sure that he will sooner or later do
that
unless he is defeated in Ukraine long
before he can use nuclear weapons you
know it sounds like it is maybe like a
Russian army in Ukraine just collapses
and they flee back home as in some kind
of disorganized balance so and then
there's some some internal revolts and
turmoils will ensue of course in Moscow
so maybe then Putin will not have much
time even to give command to use some
nuclear weapons because maybe there will
be no one already to execute this orders
but we don't see this situation yet in
the front line
and without the successful Ukrainian
attacks and the fences we may not see
that this this year or next spring for
instance so I just want to reiterate
that this massive NATO assistance is
crucial I'm sure the NATO allies when
they uh watch this you know when people
watch it we'll hear the message that you
think that the West really has to step
up and instead of trying to contain
Putin
take him on in a more muscular way my
final question to you is at the
beginning of this interview you said the
invasion of Ukraine was the beginning of
the end for President Putin this is
probably an impossible question to
answer but how does the end look like
for him do you think and when do you
think this could be over first of all he
must lose the war and as you said he is
now losing it so if this court award
isn't changed he will use it and people
know where people like their their
leaders to lose the war especially in
Russia especially with Mr Putin who
builds his image as a strong man as a
strong military military president
military ruler
so after leaving the war he would have
to explain to his Elites and to his
population why why it is so and he may
find some problems in explaining this
and there may be some opposition against
it I say maybe because we can we cannot
predict it we can just you know make our
assumptions
but the major major factor for his the
deposing or he his downfall will be the
losing of the war of course and after
that there may be a position who will
try to depose him or he will try to
purge his uh you know subordinates to
find some people who could be blamed for
all these problems and they may revolt
against him in turn so there will be a
period of internal turmoils and
I think
that's that's why Putin bets everything
on this war
because he evidently planned it to be
very short easy like you know
easy walk into Ukraine for one two weeks
and then the Ukraine is conquered and he
has this image of a great Liberator and
unites her of all uh ancient Russian
lands and so on now he has to win it at
all costs and he's already sacrificing
hundreds of thousands of his competitors
in this and he will sacrifice Millions
you should be you should have no doubts
about it he may sacrifice item 10 20
millions of Russians just to win this
war just to slaughter all ukrainians
because it's a matter of principle it's
a matter of political survival between
he understands that if he loses the war
loses war with your pain
it will be the end of you how this end
will will look like
I cannot say it for now but I don't
think it will be very pleasant for him
but it is
you know
and the the West I think must be
consistent to remove puta because
the wild Putin and his regime is still
in in power in Russia the threat of war
and threat of nuclear war will not go
anywhere okay correspondave thank you it
seems to me you're saying that it ends
in Putin losing and regime change
in Russia how that happens and over what
time frame is still so unclear but it
was so interesting to talk to you uh
thank you so much for your time
borresponder thank you thank you very
much
well that's all for today's show thank
you so much for watching we're going to
be off next week but in the fast movie
news cycle we'll see you soon again with
more interviews and stories from around
the world
thank you
[Music]